Okay, the first tag we're going to learn about is the
b-tag and it looks like this. It's got an opening
b and a closing b. There's a closing slash. And
anything that appears inside the b-tag appears bold. So, this is
b for bold. Pretty simple tag. Let's let's play around
with this in the HTML editor a little bit. Here
we are. We got this you know, this plain text
that we've typed in before. Let's let's make one of these
words bold. Okay. So, I took the word love and I preceded it
by, an opening tag and a closing tag. And when we, when we click
UPDATE here to update this. The word love is now in bold. Pretty simple
huh? Quiz time. In the box below,
make the words reasonably straightforward appear bold.